welcome to
session life after covert 19 how to
prepare for economic
social and recovery efforts uh
in the marketplace so i have my
colleague nick whitney
and uh and myself will be walking you
through some of the use cases as we
learn
in the industry uh hopefully this will
help you um
go through some thought-provoking
conversation as you look to
you know solve some of the challenges in
your uh workforce
so my name is das noble i'm the
co-founder and ceo of mtx group
and i am based out of frisco texas i've
been a lifelong
software technology engineer and also an
architect
i enjoy working in the cloud technology
especially i embraced
google cloud platform for several years
and enjoy talking to government agencies
and also private sector leaders
to make sure that we can solve some of
the real world challenges
nick thank you everybody for joining
my name is nick whitney i'm a co-founder
and cio of mtx group
i've been a cloud architect for about 15
years i've been in software for as long
as i remember
and i enjoy really using software and
cloud technologies to be able to solve
business problems
great thanks nick
so before we get started there are four
topics that we like to highlight
in this session hopefully these are
meaningful
and relevant for some of the challenges
you're looking to solve
in whether you're in the government
agencies or in a private sector
as a decision makers now there's
one thing that we're very unaware and
that is
the covet era has been unpredictable
and as part of these different stages of
the the covered era
and the way they were looking to reopen
the economy
but do it in a safe manner there are a
number of challenges that are coming up
there is no recipe for success these are
some of the conversation that we
continue to have
to collaborate and oftentimes co-create
some of the solutions
of partnering with organizations like
google cloud technology
or some other cloud technologies and
also partner with
a company like mtx to see how we can uh
innovate in this space in this
unpredictable time
today's conversation will focus on how
to
reopen workforce safely
and then we're going to talk about what
are some of the underlying challenges
that we're seeing
as part of the lockdown and social
distancing that are popping up
while protecting the the children that
are most vulnerable in our society
we'll focus on what what have we learned
as part of quality of life with this
remote workforce are there things that
we can apply going forward
after covered and make sure that we can
increase productivity
and how do we do it with the metrics
that we can be justify
there are meaningful changes that can be
brought as part of this
acceleration the digital world and then
we'll wrap it up with
insight into how can robotic process
automation is known as
rpa can help government agencies or
private sector
really embrace the remote workforce
minimize some of the the mundane
laborers task that needs to be done
manually
or it requires folks to be in the office
how can we bring some operational
efficiency
well let's get started as we dive into
these four topics
before we do dive into these four topics
a quick introduction
about mtx
mtx is a global implementation partner
that provides services for government
agencies
and private sectors around the world
we take pride in in zero failed projects
in the past six plus years while
delivering 450 projects for our clients
mtx has 420 family members within our
organization
and we're very culture-centric
organization
we take pride in investing in people
and then when we invest in people we
know that they'll invest in
clients they'll invest in some of the
innovative activities that takes place
to make sure that we continue to bring
solutions very rapidly
speaking about bringing solutions very
rapidly
in this cobit era one thing we have
learned
is that we don't necessarily have time
for projects that could take
six months seven months thing needs to
be done in weeks
if not in days so
when we are called to listen some of the
use cases of the government agencies
we're having discussions how can we
solve problems
in a matter of three to four days we
progress something quickly deploy it
and really then iterate through those
solutions with the rich feedback from
the end users
that's the summary of mtx and how we
like to innovate
let's jump into the the four topics
for today's agenda the first is the
workforce re-entry
whether you are working for the
government agencies as a cio deputy
commissioners or commissioners
or leading a private sector entities as
a cio or decision makers
or whether your parents teachers
or union leaders they're really looking
to see how can
we go back to school safely
as i mentioned there is no single
you know path in the way you can go back
and and create a safe environment these
are some meaningful conversation
that we need to continue to have as we
continue to look to our technology to
support us
in creating a safe work environment so
let's take a look at what mtx
has been doing with government agencies
and private sector
we have seen that entities with
1000 employees or 5 000 employees or 20
000 employees
up to 400 000 employees
as they are looking to reopen their
workforce
there is a significant question that
needs to be answered by the hr team and
the leadership team
is that how do we ensure a safe
environment
for the workforce to come back how do we
ensure
a safe learning environment for children
there are a number of modules mtx
developed
within the google cloud technology first
component is that wellness survey as
part of our
mobile applications there is a wellness
survey that is deployed
it consists of set of questions that
could be configured
to the needs of the specific
organization
and as part of the survey it is required
that
employees or children must fill this out
before they go back into this
environment and as part of the survey if
they do get a pass sign
then that could be utilized to have a
green light to go back to the workforce
on a daily basis now it is recommended
that individuals must take the survey
daily to make sure that there is a pulse
check
on the well-being of the individuals and
also making sure that folks that are
coming to the workforce
and bring a safe environment for them
whether you're running multiple ships as
part of your global operations
this solution will help you manage ships
i
will also help you manage your identity
and as part of the the re-entry into the
workforce
where we minimize touching different
devices within the offices
and create those identity solutions
what they're looking to do official
recognitions
and that touches the the applications
as part of validating employees versus
visitors
these are all enabling our solutions
in addition to that we have a
reservation module
that allows employees to reserve
specific cubicle
or conference rooms ahead of time before
coming to workforce
it enables workforce to really provide a
safe distance
social distancing in place to making
sure that whether you're looking for a
25
or 40 percent capacity as part of your
workforce re-entry you can manage the
capacity
and the reservation will uh honor those
settings to make sure that there's a
proper distance within the offices
the and there is another advantage to
this the reservation tool
when you are looking at cleaning the
office environments on a regular basis
if you maintain that reservation process
these information could be provided to
the cleaning services companies
to make sure that they do thorough
cleaning at the end of the day
so the environment is safe for the next
day for your
workforce overall
we do provide a command center using
bigquery and looker to visualize the
informations whether your hr
or specific business unit leaders you'll
have full visibility
whether your workforce is fully
compliant if there are risk
and all of this could be bubbled up
within the the google cloud technology
as part of our solutions
nick you have been working in this um
you know coveted uh ecosystems with
different government agencies
what else would you like to add as part
of your experience you are seeing with
the workforce re-entry thank you guys
uh one of the items that we've seen that
has been prevalent throughout all of the
engagements that we've had is that more
people are trying to do more with less
there has been restrictions on
availability and budgets in other areas
and essentially we want to ensure that
we're able to provide the best level of
service that we can
and leverage the tools that we can to
make this easy on our body
we've seen a big push to be able to
bring people back to the workforce
safely
and the survey tool allows us to use
near real-time data
to capture their ability to rejoin the
workforce safely
without having additional risks
presented to everybody else who's also
trying to
join the workforce as we look at this
data
there's a lot of risk around the
security of the data
so we also need to make sure the systems
are going to be performant
that they're secured and that we can
make the appropriate business decisions
whether we actually have access to the
underlying data
or if we just have access to aggregate
data whatever the appropriate business
goals are
ultimately those systems still need to
protect the people
and we then can make the business
decisions to protect them as they
rejoin the workforce safely
absolutely and i love the fact that you
mentioned that you know being able to do
more with less
having solution that has been rolled out
for multiple agencies or
private sectors we can bring solutions
in a very cost effective manner and
needs to be rolled out within 48 hours
so we'll absolutely love to have this
conversation and showcase how we can
innovate with google cloud technology
all right so uh thank you nick we'll
jump into the next topic
and that is child welfare there is part
of this social distancing and lockdown
there is a troubling numbers that are
popping up in our society
where kids being stuck at home not being
able to go back to school
or not being able to collaborate with
their friends and peers
there are challenges at a household
where
the number of children abuse and neglect
are rising
and they will continue to rise if you
are a decision maker within the
government agencies
you may be challenged with what can we
do in the short term what can you do in
the long term strategy
what can you do with where some of the
solutions have been rolled out
whether you're supporting the child care
agencies whether you're supporting
the foster care agencies the foster
parents
what can be done to make sure that we're
creating a safe environment for children
let's dive into some of the specific
things what mtx has built within the
google cloud technology
to make sure that that you do not
necessarily have to
reinvent the will we can absolutely
repurpose our solutions to make sure
that
things that has been rolled out that are
meaningful and provide meaningful value
to the society in keeping children safe
whether you're looking at the the foster
parent
or or child care providers we are able
to provide
our child protective services solutions
that
has a comprehensive solutions including
oversight into
the different subsidiary program to make
sure that if
people or foster parents are really
abusing children
they should not be subsidized and there
is a way to bubble out those information
so we absolutely recommend
taking a look at having assistance i
mean we're way past
doing things in paper or excel
spreadsheet
let's embrace the cloud technology that
has been built by mtx within the google
cloud technology to really have those
visibility
there are awful lot of data that are out
there but i believe that
we can take the data and and provide a
meaningful informations
we can lead that into actionable
insights
and then have real change in the society
in keeping children safe
in addition to that making sure that
whether the foster parent
or the the daycare providers are really
being compliant and and providing a
safer environment
mtx built a background record check
applications that could be rolled out to
these different
use cases and making sure that we're
managing risk
as part of the managing risk we need to
be able to understand
what are some of the regulatory status
that we need to make sure that we
are compliant and also making sure that
we're enforcing those on a regular basis
and be able to do some of the
inspections visit using cloud technology
such as google meet and whether you
schedule these
remote visits or in-person visits
there's certain ways you can use this
technology as you go
and be able to have those informations
bubble up so you can have an
informed decision-making process as part
of your agencies
now we do look at creating a safer
environment for
children whether it is back to school
and
solutions or really creating a solution
for the essential workforce
um you know whether they can put their
kids in a daycare
um all of these solutions are really
relevant in how you could promote and
have a meaningful
insightable informations to make
informed decisions
in the way you digitize and transform
now
it is a common sense to say that well
why wouldn't we create a safer
environment for children
well it's really difficult when you have
a paper-based systems
or really antiquated systems or systems
that do not talk to each other
our comprehensive child protective
solutions
really enable decision makers to have
insight into the different activities
across different business units
and bubble up information is that if
providers or foster parents are really
breaking the rule
and and creating an unsafe environment
for children then some of the subsidiary
program could be free
frozen and in certain penalty could be
imposed to make sure that we continue to
create a safer environment for the
children
all right so let's take a look at the
the next topic which is the quality of
life
whether you are decision makers a cio
level or deputy commissioners or
you know business unit leaders this is a
constant conversation
is that is this safe for us to go back
to work
or how should we really roll out the
strategy
there is a meaningful conversation to
have and that is
is the dual need to rush in your
strategy
to put everyone back into workforce
right
what are some meaningful insight in
terms of is there benefits having
folks working remotely right and if you
do what are some of the things you need
to be aware of
we strongly recommend using google cloud
technology create a collaborative
environment a connected community
there is the the research has shown that
when you create a connected community
for the remote workforce using the right
tool and technology for collaboration
you create happy workforce when you
create a happy workforce there is a
direct correlation to product
increase in productivity so we strongly
recommend that
as you are dealing with this
unpredictable time to look at the cloud
technology such as google cloud platform
to make sure that
we can enable those collaboration tools
uh including the google meet to make
sure that the your employees feel
connected
the next you're going to be looked to
accelerate the
the digital transformation this year
with the kobet responses it kind of
forced us to really look at this and
really
accelerate all of our needs in that
aspect
the good news is you do have some care
act funding
that will expire at the end of the year
some of you have already accelerated
those digital transformation
there are some of those other
technologies that you may have that you
can potentially bring with the google
cloud technology
and also subsidize those with those care
act funding
and support your remote workforce
as part of that process to set up some
metric
right in terms of whether you care about
the teleport work-life balance
or connected community that increases
you know
productivity in the workforce have those
meaningful metrics that are defined
and also rules are built out using our
solutions within the google cloud
technology
using bigquery and lookers you can
visualize at the organization level or
at the business unit level
and this will ensure that as you're
supporting the remote workforce
or there is an incremental slow process
to get back to normalcy
there is a way you can support the
quality of life
for your remote workforce using google
technology
with that being said we're on the last
topic and nick i'll turn it over to you
for the robotic process automation
thank you guys as we look at the theme
of doing more with less
we have a lot of ability to improve our
worker experience at the same time that
we reduce the amount of effort that
we're putting into
standardized workflows we really want to
be able to automate our repetitive
actions
we want to be able to increase our
quality and we want to be able to reduce
the human error it's associated with
these manual
actions you want to minimize any manual
tasks
and start to be able to move those into
system-based workflows
as we look at the bots that are
available to us or that we can build
we have a lot of areas of improvement
finance has the ability to streamline
their ap and ar including things like
vendor onboarding
where they may no longer be able to
bring people into an office to be able
to sign paperwork
and be able to actually handle that in
person they now need to be able to do
this remotely
so we can set up the bots that allow
them to streamline this process that
would have historically been done
as we look at the approvals we want to
be able to automate those those are no
longer again going to be stamped they're
not going to be
in inc we want to be able to move those
into a system
as we look at hr especially with some of
the challenges that come out from cobit
of perhaps standing in call centers or
responding to issues that they may not
historically have handled we want to be
able to automate the onboarding
orchestrate the systems that need to be
put together as we look
at doing that automation of the
onboarding we can increase our
responsiveness
and improve our worker experience by
using bots to be responsive to what
comes back from those people
if we have forms that need to be sent
out we have signatures that are required
we can ensure that those processes are
streamlined efficient
and providing a good worker experience
to people who may not have as much
experience with those flows
as we look at these tools there's also a
great example here of being able to use
an iai tool one of the ai tools that
we've suggested is a maverick ai tool
which is our internal maver platform
this has been built on the google cloud
platform and allows us to
reduce the amount of effort that is
spent on
tasks that are lower value those tasks
can instead be done by the platform
and allow us to do something like
scanning documents to ensure that they
are accurately filled out
and sending them back out to the people
if they're not completed
and whatever rules based platform
actions we need to be able to follow
this allows us to focus our people's
time and energy
where there's higher value and instead
of having them scan 100 of the documents
they may only need to be involved with
20 of the documents they can review
those and be far more efficient
is there anything you would add yeah
absolutely i think um
you know nick your organization at mtx
really leads the whole ai platform
initiatives
and i get always a warm and fuzzy
feeling when i see that some of those
bots or some of these technologies
you're bringing in
and oftentimes educate us is that as a
leader
as we're looking to really minimize some
of the manual tasks and how can the bots
could be realized now
as a decision maker if you have the
funding to really you know go through
the digital transformation
and and invest in the google cloud
technology
and replace your existing systems great
if you don't have the luxury we take a
look at it in the rpa process with
maverick af platform
how can you really solve some of those
challenges now nick
let's talk about you know there's a lot
of folks who will talk about it will
aiza you know buzzwords
um we are seeing some real world
examples
we're solving real world problems for
government agencies in the private
sector
um if i'm a cio what can
what can i uh look toward in terms of
preparations
um uh in solving some of my challenges
using a how do i start
so what we like to do is we like to
start with a journey map of
if we were able to kind of look into the
future and say what does a perfect state
look like
we want to understand that vision and
understand that business
what that allows us to do then is kind
of look at what is maybe a low-hanging
fruit sometimes things
look like they're going to be more
complex but it's something you can
actually do
in a far more efficient fashion allows
you to pilot the functionality
ensure that you're comfortable with it
start to build that out over time
it doesn't necessarily need to be that
we boil the ocean on day one we can
solve a signal business problem
free up some resources and then move on
to the next business problem
ultimately that kind of evaluation of
the security evaluation of the workflow
and starting out
in a measured and controlled fashion is
something that we've seen be very
successful and start to really free up
those resources
to move on to the next area where
there's better you know focus and better
area
or improvement for us absolutely and
thanks nick and obviously
privacy and security are the topmost
priority for
your r d team as you continue to
innovate in that space
um i do welcome any questions or any
conversation from other cios or decision
makers
to really connect with nick whitney and
and see how we can help you as you look
to migrate into the google cloud
technology
and also utilize our maverick ar
platform in some of the decision making
process
this will be the end of our presentation
i appreciate you spending the time with
us
hopefully you found these topics to be
thought provoking as you have
conversation with your colleagues
with your peers or even at a dinner
table in the way that we're all
addressing some of these kobe related
challenges my name is das noble
and i'm the co-founder and ceo of mtx
nick whitney
i'm the co-founder and cio of tx thank
you